heather how are we doing um i am
in the middle of a divorce after 16
years with two kids
i woke up in july
and my husband and kids had left and
i was diagnosed bipolar after that
and i think the biggest
issue i'm having is how to
deal with the shame and regret
that i have because i'm not getting the
opportunity to fix
what's been broken um
and so how do i sit
in move forward when it's been
something that's been my responsibility
i um you know i know that there are
some people that say that it takes two
in a marriage but there
is when there's a mental illness
involved too
there's a part of me that says you know
this was all my responsibility this was
all my doing
i didn't know what do i do so what did
you do to make him leave
um honestly i was arguing with my
my pre-teen daughter quite a bit okay
and
um in mania i had spoken with somebody
else over the phone that i had known
from my childhood so you argued with
your daughter
and forget the mania part okay i wanna
disassociate here from the bipolar stuff
i just wanna talk to you directly okay
so take the bipolar glasses off and just
wanna hear what are the
things you did to break up a 16-year
marriage okay
so you argued with your pre-teen
daughter
yes all right and that makes you one
nobody does that by the way so that's
all on you
and then what's next did you do i'm
being sarcastic by the way what next
the other thing is you on the phone
talk to somebody i flirted with and that
i flirted with another man yeah
okay so you flirt another man did you go
meet him up in a hotel and hook up with
him
no i did not i never even facetimed with
him
i'm dude i'm so old now i i'm not
laughing at you
i realize there's all these new
technological ways to cheat and they're
all like new
i'm just a loser okay so you argued and
you flirted what else did you do
i planned um
to have this escape mode in my head of
well it it was back in middle school it
was
a group of us we all had this like
10-year plan that if none of us were
happy we'd all run away together type
thing
and sweet yeah and it was
it started out as a joke but it became
the five-year plan when he and i got on
the phone and so there was a lot of
fantasy land involved in there
i wasn't
i wasn't doing my wifey job he was i
wasn't giving him the attention he
wasn't giving me the attention and so
therefore i created it
over the phone with somebody else fair
okay
best way i can describe that right so
you had a disconnected relationship
and you begin to outsource that
connection other places
yes that's correct and so
i want to put the bipolar aside for a
second okay
and the things that you've told me here
if you were manic often um
that can be exhausting to live with is
that fair
it is exhausting to deal with and live
with i grew up with it my mother
was bipolar okay um and then when it
comes to
the low season give me an example of
what a low period would be like for you
um there'd be sleeping there be i
wouldn't be sleeping at night so i'd be
sleeping in like i think i did my best
sleeping from like 9 to 11
when my girls were in school and then
you know i would get up and that was
most of my low season but
i had been on medication for anxiety for
15 plus years and what would happen is
every it seemed like every six months i
would go through the
cycle where i'd have um
just the only emotion i could tap into
was anger i
like i didn't when my dad died i didn't
cry when
things happened i didn't cry there
wasn't okay
either okay it's okay or angry i just
listen to the picture you're painting me
okay
your dad passes away you grow up in a
house with a bipolar mom
when did your dad die how old were you
uh he died three years ago
okay from uh cancer it was from day to
diagnosis was 31 days
geez louise yeah yeah it was absolutely
heartbreaking
right
so you grow up in a home that's a mess
that's chaos right
and you're finding defense strategies
and you're finding
connection strategies wherever you can
get them
you've been experiencing this low level
burn
sometimes a high loud fire alarm burn
of anxiety for 15 years that tells me
you've been in
a semi-connected or unconnected marriage
for
15 years doesn't mean you don't love
this guy doesn't mean he's not great he
may be a great guy
um that may mean that you're tough to
live with and your
the strategies you learned growing up
plugged into his strategies that he
learned growing up and y'all just have
had this
anxious connected disconnected dance for
15 years
yeah all that to say is
i don't want you walking around with
this gigantic cinder block
of shame that you are at fault
and more importantly now you've got
something to point to and blame it on
which is a mental health diagnosis
i want you just to back up and own it
that it takes it as cheesy as it sounds
they're right
it takes two to tango it does
and at some point the disconnection got
to your husband and he walked out the
door
and arguing and flirting
and creating other checkpoints
or not um
that's not why you cash in on a marriage
it's just not
okay i didn't think so either but i just
have
there's so much embarrassment that comes
with what i did because i truly did love
my husband and my children
and then there comes the shame of
knowing that
there is a mental health diagnosis and
i didn't take care of it before and i
didn't know i really truly thought
it was just an anxiety diagnosis and it
what i was seeing people and going to
therapy
i went to outpatient sense i'm on
different medication i'm in therapy
twice a week and trying to do anything
and everything i can
to repair everything but he's just he's
not
willing if you
are continuing to chase down what was
you're never gonna get well you're never
gonna find wholeness
okay and so this is going to be another
loss and a line of losses for you
and it's going to hurt and it sounds
like you haven't fully
put the guard down and grieved it yet is
that fair
i've grieved quite a bit but i am
crying is different than grieving yeah i
think there's still a part of me that
hopes
that you know there will be a fixable
moment after
16 years and the well aren't i worth it
isn't the family worth it type situation
right
and when you start putting external
worths
on your internal wholeness man you are
going to start chasing all sorts
of all sorts of different behaviors
different people different actions
trying to plug that hole up
okay what you what you're doing right
now working on yourself you've got to do
it for one reason it's because
heather's worth being well that's it
and a well whole
who deals with her childhood trauma and
if you grow up in the house of someone
who's truly bipolar
and i say this a lot on the show bipolar
is much much rarer than it's diagnosed
okay um if you grew up in the home of
somebody who's truly bipolar then you
grew up in a
marriage that was challenging right you
grew up with a model of a marriage that
was challenging
it wouldn't surprise me if your dad had
to figure out ways to check in and plug
into other things that would connect him
to
um he was an addict okay there you go
and
um i just had the caller before this
addiction is a connection issue right
and so then you get an addict and a
bipolar person in a room
and then they start a dance you start
you absorb that right you grow up with
trauma and you
just do that dance all over again and
your husband participated in that dance
for 16 years
okay here's all i'm telling you i want
you to exhale
and just stop running okay
just put your shoulders down and you're
gonna have to find somebody if you're
going to counseling twice a week if
you're seeing a therapist twice a week
that's a great place to start
but crying is different than grieving
grieving is ownership it is
with a period at the end of it and then
it is letting that
part wash over you and if you are
bipolar
if you are being medicated if you enter
the care of a mental health professional
i recommend you do it with them because
they're going to walk you through it
but i want you to when do you go see
your your therapist next
this week when i get off the phone with
you oh great awesome so here's what i
want you to do
i want you to go and say
i am trying to fix my marriage still and
that's a noble
like right thing to do i'm i'm proud of
you for
saying i'm not giving up i'm not giving
up until that core document's
final okay but you can't change his mind
he laughed
and rightly or wrongly um
you are no not rightly or wrongly if
it's because
arguing preteen flirted and you start
checking other places
in my head that's not a reason to walk
out on a marriage
um my guess is there's probably more to
it than that and if i had him on the
phone he'd probably have a whole other
narrative but
what i'm telling you is he contributed
fully to the picture that you're that
you're now staring at
okay i want you to go to your counselor
i want you to tell her
that i am ready to grieve i've got to
just
acknowledge what is happening to me and
i need some help
grieving okay
i want you to go get david kessler's
book finding meaning and i want you to
read that book
i want you to ask your therapist to read
that book and i want them to walk you
through it and if you have a good
therapist
who is interested in partnering with you
in your mental health journey they will
be excited to get a new
read and to partner with you because
you're taking ownership of your wellness
you're not outsourcing it to somebody
you're not just spending time blaming
i don't know that you're at the blame
and shame part i think you are still
in the grieving part and you've got to
just sit down and exhale
and own this when it comes to bipolar
now you've got your diagnosis
they may be able to give you some
medication they may be able to give you
some strategies that you're going to
have to
work on now and for years but you've got
a lot of trauma healing to do here
and so i hope that your therapist is
well and good and knows what they're
doing
at the end of the day i want to make
sure you know
that as cliche as it sounds it takes two
people to be in a relationship
and 14 years ago your husband
could have come to you and said we are
two years in
you are anxious all the time i'm not
able to make a safe space for you and i
don't know why and i want us to get
help and i want to start healing now and
you grew up in the home of an addict and
a bipolar mom
i want to be a part of a healing process
i want to learn some new strategies
strategies on how i can create a safe
welcoming vulnerable home for you to be
here in whole and fulling
and he didn't do that he left he took
your kids and he left
i want you to be well and i want you to
be whole and here's the other thing you
haven't lost your kids
you got to reach reach out and you got
to show back up to your kids
you don't make promises that you can't
keep you got to continue to take your
medication and continue to do the work
that you know you need to do so that one
day you're not on medication anymore
you've created some boundaries in your
life so when you do have
high seasons and low seasons you've got
governors on your life and that may mean
look
i'm heading into a high season i need to
give my debit card to somebody else
or i'm heading into a low season i'm
going to fill in the blank right
but don't make bipolar your identity
you're
heather from austin freaking texas
you're a mom
you're a good woman you grew up in a
mess and you've got trauma that you've
got to work through
and it's going to take a season but
don't give up on yourself don't just
throw up your hands and say well i got
bipolar that's that
no ma'am you're worth more than that so
heather
i want you to have that conversation
with your therapist tonight i'm
fascinated to know what what they say
i would love to have a client come in
and say
i got this new book i'm ready to get in
the deep end here it's going to start
with me grieving this
loss i want you to tell your husband
i hate that we're breaking this up i
feel like i'm still worth it
if you're going to leave it breaks my
heart and let there be a period at the
end of that sentence
tell your daughters you're not ever
going to give up on them you love them
you're always going to be connected to
them you're always going to be with them
and then you got to put the work in
every single day